okay it looks like it is on your boy
psychobabble here what am I looking at
here Charlie big eye Charlie lets us see
what's going on here and I kinda just
see oh hey y'all glad trying to hold on
to a job but alas
Charlie suffered from user interaction
idea a new rod removing wood allows you
to do these words for him and your what
that means so he gets fired Charlie in
front of a live studio audience
it's easy yes before II no go ahead
press play in ruin Charlie the knife oh
man hey is s very tall he's pitching a
sound with TV executive the greatest
people in the world what kind of a
stupid idea is that boy that kid was to
say random words that Buer chose for him
who would want to see that you scum of
the earth see words yeah he's come
actually nothing up get out of my office
yeah no I really need this job sir
my mom is raising the rent I don't want
to live in the street you like bi shut
up you can give me one more idea but it
better be brilliant
Oh God they better pay yes sir I can
assure you that means gonna be the best
idea you've ever heard you in your life
snoop
it's up it's a show voice is so high a
to a TV show about a tooth oh don't you
notice Jesus Awards annual these are in
this year you know just know you aren't
you interested in kid no whoa really
couldn't wait to answer that woman why
is it at - does it symbolize anything
special to you yeah yeah there's a tooth
your mother's at - Oh disgusting yeah
tell me more about his nose is so funny
well not much to say really not
much I like this carburetor theater
being a allows that so this tooth which
is the main character of the show what
does it do it killed jay-z - jay-z
it kills Jesus how are you gonna get
yeah she must do your show not jay-z the
rapper jay-z the Texaco there's the text
accountant called jay-z yeah you
actually a very famous car you know
something victim s gz the Texaco no
you're very good you know knows the
multiplication table boy Martin you for
sex for what's that photos right yes BT
is 16 actually succeed let's give it up
give it up for Charlie Charlie Oh got it
right Charlie Charlie Charlie tell me
what does be to 106 LJ singer excuse me
no it's a thing that is not a thing
there's where I come from where are you
from well Carolina I'm from South
Carolina I can assure you that is messed
up saying of that kind or enough I am
also from North Carolina and I can
assure you that once again so angry a
cactus is lit sharp oh cool and it is
curving and smooth and then Bobby
how did so let me get on this straight
it's a show about a to that kills jay-z
in order to a cactus yeah as a call to
show what do you say that loud you know
that is the most
brilliant amazing idea I have ever heard
okay what I want ten seasons of your
show on the air by next week seasons
Wallace that's where too many finishes
just so apparently change my mind
I want 20 seasons by NYX we 27th open
pressure
mild panic attack put under pressure
good all right Charles no longer on
episode should be second ten seconds
brilliant really you don't think that's
a bit too short no no that'd be perfect
amount of time
oh it's now the Jews that killed Jamie
nor did you get a cat oh hey hey Jay Z
we got the animated Emma to kill you
because because I wanna I wanna I wanna
cactus that's why so I'm sorry but
you're gonna have to give your life like
a cactus
what oh and you want to tell me we have
20 seasons of this well really did a
number on my soul they're gonna tell you
haven't slept in a week but it's been
awful
well char Bo not only have you brought
orable shame to us to yourself and
everyone involved in this catastrophic
piece of unholy crap
you have also wasted the valuable time
and money of the American people what do
you have to say for yourself
oh my god
howdy-doo you're fine okay so sorry
oh hello everyone I hope you enjoyed
this episode if you did please subscribe
click to subscribe
you know clicking and also share this on
social media and stuff yep they'll be
great and they're basically you know
just to be on the safe side just like
anything you see on the screen ur
Twitter yes Twitter whatever guilt
that's that stuff do whatever you could
I said Facebook did my face I think I
felt like okay to wait you know I was
getting it you know quite where I just
died that Twitter already how many times
could I mention Twitter yeah to share it
on Twitter I don't care anymore I was
you know I wasn't even paid to say this
I don't know why we're okay you just
keep saying so I'm pretty sure - yes
this guy's not from our production team
is just deranged and keep stealing
Twitter for no reason
so okay bye oh hello everyone I hope you
enjoyed this episode if you did please
subscribe click to subscribe
you know clicking whoop and also share
this on social media and stuff yep
they'll be great and they're basically
you know just to be on the safe side
just like anything you see on the screen
er Twitter yes Twitter whatever y'all
that's that stuff do whatever you guys
like my book didn't I say I think okay
anyway you know what I just say